لا يمكن ان يكون هناك عمل كالمعتاد مع
روسيا ولن يكون هناك عمل معها في المستقبل
طالما الحرب الروسيه الوحشيه مستمره على
اوكرانيا
من مخلفات السوفيات عندما دخلوا برلين
وحرروها من النازيين هي تقف في قلب
العاصمه الالمانيه على بعد امتار قليله
فقط من بوابه ومن خلفها مقر المستشاريه
والبوندستان لم يشكل وجود هذه الدبابات
هنا جدلا الا بعد ان اندلعت الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبدات المانيا تراجع علاقتها
بروسيا ورغم المطالبات بازاله الدبابات
التي تحولت نصفا تذكريا تعهدت المانيا بعد
خسارتها الحرب بالحفاظ عليها فهي ما زالت
هنا يعكس هذا الجدل الحاله التي تعيشها
المانيا منذ عام والتي تجسدت بازمه دبابات
التي ترددت حكومه المستشار
بتسليمها لكيف فالاشتراكيون هم من اسسوا
لسياسه التقارب مع الاتحاد السوفيتي في
السبعينات
المحلل الاليكسي يوسف من معهد فريدريش
ابره المقرب من الاشتراكيين يقول ان هذا
جعل من مراجعه الاشتراكيين لسياستهم مع
روسيا اليوم مهما صعبه ومؤلمه
من الواضح ان العلاقه الخاصه بين المانيا
وروسيا تضررت وهذا مؤلم بالنسبه
للاشتراكيين ولكن ايضا اتخاذ مبادره
عسكريه لا يتماشى مع الثقافه السائده في
برلين المانيا لا تتخذ مبادره عسكريه ورغم
ان الاشتراكيين كانوا هم من اسسوا لسياسه
التقارب مع روسيا فان المستشاره السابقه
لمحافظه انجيلا ميركل اكملتها رئيسه قسم
العلاقات الدوليه في معهد كنرد ادنىور
المقرب من الحزب المسيحي الديمقراطي الذي
تنتمي اليه ماركل تقول ان المانيا كانت
ساذجه في سياستها مع روسيا ولم تستمع
للتحذيرات الكثيره
بعد سقوط الجدار في برلين ظننا ان
بامكاننا بناء امن مشترك مع روسيا ولفتره
طويله اعتقدنا ان بامكاننا العيش اصدقاء
ولكن اكتشفنا متاخرين باننا لا يمكننا
بناء امن مشترك مع روسيا سياسه التقارب
التي يقول الالمان ان الحرب البارده
فرضتها وتاريخ المانيا مع القوه العسكريه
يجعلان برلين تبدو اليوم متردده ولكن من
الواضح بان تاريخ المانيا واشباحه مازالا
يطارضانها راغده بهنام العربيه برلين